bonjour verra bienvenue dans la matinale
de rtl france comment est ce que les
autorités font face à cette hausse des
contaminations et des décès bonjour
magal est en fait toujours pas de
confinement en vue mais selon le maire
de moscou il n'y a qu'une chose qui peut
arrêter la pandémie une vaccination
rapide et à grande échelle
mais même si le nombre des personnes
vaccinées vient de dépasser deux
millions dans la capitale ce n'est pas
assez pour les mégapoles de 15 millions
qui est moscou je vous propose d'écouter
il n'y a qu'une chose qui peut arrêter
la pandémie une vaccination rapide et à
grande échelle
bien sûr il faut respecter des exigences
sanitaires il faut respecter le régime
de port du masque dans les transports en
commun dans les lieux publics dans les
commerces
mais toutes ces mesures portent à
caractère temporaire afin de résoudre
radicalement ce problème il faut
vacciner ou instaurer un confinement
tous fermés très bien rade mettons que
vous avez tous fermés deux ou trois
semaines se sont écoulées
le nombre de cas a diminué et vous
ouvrez de nouveau et ça repart et ainsi
de suite à l'infini mais cela ne peut
pas continuer ainsi de nouvelles
restrictions entre en vigueur à moscou
et dans sa banlieue ce lundi les chefs
d'entreprises seront obligés de rétablir
le télétravail pour 30 % des employés
non d'auxigny l'accès aux restaurants et
cafés se fera désormais par le biais
d'un code qr qui sera disponible
uniquement à ceux qui en test pcr
négatif un certificat de vaccination
complète encore un justificatif des
anticorps valable six mois après la
maladie
le nombre des contaminations tendance
partout en russie plus de vingt mille
nouveaux cas de corona virus ont été
enregistrés dans le pays ces dernières
24 heures dont presque 7000 à moscou
merci beaucoup verra pour toutes ces
explications verhaeghe hoffman en direct
de moscou